sure
yeah okay okay uh so
good afternoon good morning or good
evening wherever you are
uh it's my very great pleasure to
welcome you to this latest simon's
institute talk
um uh the speaker today is thomas sanjo
thomas sandholm is the angel jordan
university professor of computer science
at carnegie mellon university
and he describes himself as a serial
entrepreneur his research focuses on the
convergence of ai
economics and operations research and
one of the many remarkable things about
thomas is that he's made fundamental
lasting and significant contributions in
each of those
areas uh he's won a string of uh
of awards in recognition of his research
these include
uh the marvin minsky medal from ichikai
the ichikai computers and thought award
he was the recipient
of the inaugural acm autonomous agents
research award in 2001.
uh he's a fellow of the acm of triple ai
and informs and he holds an honorary
doctorate from the university of zurich
he's an extremely prolific researcher
and
one whose research is always absolutely
of the highest international standard
and so to honor it's my very great
pleasure to be able to welcome you
uh to give today's talk on finding and
certifying near optimal strategies
in black box extensive extensive form
imperfect information games the floor is
yours
well thank you very much for that very
kind introduction
can you hear me properly
okay so um i'm gonna start out by
talking a little bit about the big
picture of game solving and how that's
really changed
dramatically over the last 17 years or
so
and uh then uh and kind of my thinking
about
how to think about game solving and then
i'm going to jump to the
specific technical topic and that
technic technical topic
is finding and certifying near optimal
strategies in
optimal strategies in black box
extensive form imperfect information
games
and that part is joint work with my
great phd student
brian huzan okay
so there has been amazing progress
in game solving over the last 17 years
and a big part of this was work
on computer poker in the ai community
the scalability let's say oh
imperfect information game solving has
really jumped
uh dozens of orders of magnitude over
the last over that time
so if you think about um in look at 95
say at around 95 the biggest imperfect
information game that had been solved
had about 140 000 nodes in the game tree
and today we have superhuman strategies
for games that are of the size of 10 to
the power of
165 nodes in the game tree
so you can see that there's been
dramatic improvement
and i don't actually think about
game solving anymore as like one
algorithm
or here's an algorithm for solving a
game it's uh better than this thing or
so on
and nowadays i think of game solving as
kind of
different modules that address different
aspects and get glued together into
these different pipelines
of game solving and we are doing that in
both my academic research group at
carnegie mellon
and at my startup company strategy robot
and strategic machine
same kind of thinking maybe a little bit
different technologies
what are the modules well um one
is automated abstraction that's a key
module
so how do we actually take the game
and make some sort of a smaller game
that strategically identical or
strategically similar
so that when we solve the abstract game
we can get good strategies for the
original game
and there's really two different sides
it started
from state abstraction algorithms and
some sort of automated timing going on
here let me just turn that off
hmm
okay that should be better so uh
state abstraction first and then more
recently action abstraction
and now both of those can be done with
guarantees
on solution quality so you can guarantee
that uh
when you solve the abstract game either
you get an exact equilibrium in the
original game
or something within a bound of
equilibrium where the pound
depends on measurable aspects on the
difference between the abstraction
and and the real world another module
that's really important
is real time sub game solving it used to
be
that of course in perfect information
games like chess
or go um you did real time sub game
solving these actually go back
as ideas at least to the 50s with
checkers checkers program
and when we teach ai we oftentimes talk
about game solving like this
that there's some sort of search
algorithm there's a limited depth
horizon
there's an evaluation function and so on
but uh this was not doable for imperfect
information games
for several reasons and uh
only in the last few years really the
last five years or so
real-time sub-game solving has become
possible in imperfect information games
and even more recently depth limited
real time sub game solving
so the history went first you know just
solving the end game
typically in a finer grained abstraction
and the whole game
could be afforded to solve and then more
recently
mid-game solving and so now you can
actually do this in
imperfect information games as well
equilibrium finding algorithms uh
lots of work of course there and that's
probably where most of the work has gone
into and by the way here i'm only
showing
uh work and modules from my lab but on
these modules
there's been a lot of work from other
ai groups as well and in those papers
that i'm citing here you can find all of
those
references so equilibrium finding
algorithms there's really two main
families nowadays
there's regret minimization algorithms
based on counterfactual regret
minimization
and real
offline first error optimization methods
and the latter have a better worst case
convergence rate
but the former just continued to be
better both are improving by orders of
magnitude but the regret minimization
base somehow
continue to be a little bit uh better
which is actually a kind of a paradox
that i
want to continue to try to solve as i
have been for
the last 10 years
incorporating deep learning now you can
actually incorporate deep learning
uh for various purposes in these
these algorithms and oftentimes you can
actually have these algorithms that have
guarantees and then you just put a deep
learning box in there
and that actually ruins the guarantees
but you can say that
if the deep learning box does the right
thing then the whole thing still has the
guarantees
so in a sort of way it's a part of a
guaranteed framework pruning
uh of course pruning like alpha beta
pruning has been a classic in
imperfect information game solving but
now you can do it in
imperfect information game solving i
mean now you can do it in
imperfect information games as well
there it's trickier
because the values of the different
parts of the game tree
keep changing during the solve so some
of the pruned parts of the
tree turn out to be actually not
prunable after all
and you have to bring them back into
play and then you have to warm start
their iterations with clever techniques
as if you had never pruned them in the
first place and so on
similarly warm starting these cfr based
techniques it was believed that you
can't warm start them
but if you do it in a really clever way
it's actually possible to warm start
them and that allows you to start from
for example strategies that have been
computed in course or abstractions
or strategies that have been computed
with some techniques that don't have
guarantees like reinforcement learning
um or manual insights manually made
strategies
and so on automatically specified lp for
equilibrium finding
so it used to be that lp was a state of
the art for solving two-player zero-sum
games
until uh about 2008
where new techniques started coming
through but recently lp has become
again competitive by automatic
specification of the lp
first and then computing equilibria by
incorporating qualitative models that's
the idea
sometimes you have intuition about what
the answer might look like
some sort of qualitative intuition what
strategy should look like
you can actually incorporate that now
into some of these equilibrium finding
algorithms and that allows you to solve
these problems
faster and it sometimes actually allows
you to solve game
classes that are not solvable without
those qualitative
insights i don't mean just
computationally but with
it there are no algorithms for those
classes once you put the
qualitative insights in they start to
fall into a different class for which
algorithms exist
and the nice thing about that is that
these qualitative insights
they can be guesses and the guesses
don't have to be right
so the solver will actually say it okay
well your insights
were wrong there is no equilibrium that
satisfies those qualitative insights
algorithms for equilibrium refinements
lots of work on that of course
and just to highlight one example the
main
equilibrium refinement for extensive
form imperfect information games
is trembling hand equilibria and those
were wildly unsolvable
until three years ago you could solve
games with maybe a handful of notes
now we can exactly solve games with
around 30 000 sequences or so
so not to the same level as nash for
poker
but still to reasonably sized game
models
self-improvement techniques this is
actually kind of a nice new kind of way
of
including human insight in this
so you can um and this started from our
work on libraries
where one of the three modules was
self-improvement and it's not what you
might think
uh you might think that it's trying to
find weaknesses in the opponent and
trying to tweak your strategy to exploit
them
it's not that it's looking at what are
some actions that opponents have taken
that have been outside of our
abstraction
and looking at those
as to how far were they from our
abstraction
and then filling those in into the
abstraction
and solving those parts of the game tree
cleverly so the whole game still glues
into an equilibrium
so you can actually refine the
abstraction
as you're using the tool based on
what the adversaries have actually
played
so that way if the adversaries invent
some
completely new strategies say that your
algorithm didn't have to happen to
consider in self-play
that will actually get get fixed as you
play against the adversary finding
correlated and course correlated
equilibria
algorithms for multiplayer games again
multiplayer games even in normal form
are extremely difficult
but we show that by using these steps
limited search techniques
uh you can actually do superhuman play
for example
in multiplayer poker no limit texas hold
them with six players
and solving team games with pre-game
correlation in the team
and opponent of exploitation this is the
idea that you can look at
how the opponent plays either based on
historical data
or based on actually online data as you
play them
and you can start to exploit the
opponent's weaknesses
the downside with that is by and large
that as you exploit the opponent
you become open to exploitation yourself
but we showed that that
trade-off doesn't actually start at zero
so you can exploit more
than any game theoretic strategy would
and still be completely safe yourself
and we actually do a lot of hybrids
where you start from a game theoretic
strategy and then you can start tweaking
your strategy in parts of the search
space
towards exploiting your opponent when
you have a lot of data
about opponents in those parts so as you
can see now there's
lots of different modules here and
depending on the application area you
might want to glue them together which
modules do you bring in
which algorithms within the modules and
so on
so uh it's no longer the case that hey
here i have a new algorithm for solving
a game
you might have a new algorithm for some
module
in these pipelines and so on
okay so one of the issues and now i'm
starting to move towards
the problem that i'm going to talk about
today one of the issues
that we've seen a lot in my startup
companies working on game solving
is the question that customers asked
what if the game model is inaccurate or
unknown
so you're solving a game model and
you're getting
a good solution to the model but what if
the model isn't reality
and how do you even know if the model is
reality
and one kind of practical answer is
sensitivity analysis
so change the model tweak the model
and then resolve it see if the answers
are similar if so then you can be pretty
sure that the recommendations are robust
to changes in the model
now moving to the more theoretical side
of that
i mentioned this lossy game abstraction
techniques with
epsilon exploitability guarantees and
this is uh
something that i started with satinder
singh on
stochastic games and then with my phd
student christian cruer
we had this sequence of papers that
extended that to
real extensive form games so we can
actually guarantee
that if you solve an abstraction
and can prove that the abstraction
if the abstraction is close to the
reality the strategies that come out of
the abstraction
are close to optimal for the real game
not just for the model
so while this was motivated by
computational speed
and was looking at the gap between
a game model and abstraction it occurred
to me that you can actually use the
exact same
uh theory to bound the gap between
reality and the game model the earlier
gap there
now the third
approach here and this is what i'm going
to talk about today
is the first techniques for computing
probably
optimal strategies equilibrium
strategies or near equilibrium
strategies
while searching only a tiny fraction of
the game tree
and this um was motivated by some
thoughts that i had
kind of more like hopes
i had it as we were working at strategy
robot
so i was looking at these huge games
uh that were only given by simulator
access
and it seemed at first that you'd have
to try
everything try all possible strategies
for player one and for player two and
all players
and before you can actually guarantee
anything
and then i started thinking that maybe
that's not the
case like if you're playing let's say
some sort of a real-time
strategy game maybe if you've made a
terrible mistake somewhere in the middle
of the game
as an example maybe you know that that
was a bad action
before playing down the rest of the path
or if the opponent has made a terrible
action maybe you know it's terrible
already right there and you don't have
to play the rest of the game
so that gave me the hope that maybe we
can actually
compute actual equilibria in these games
without actually searching the whole
game
and turns out now that you can and this
is brand new work from just uh
last year and this year we give an
algorithm with
the optimal convergence of o tilde
number of nodes divided by square root
of t
convergence in this setting and this is
very different from prior methods
that can be exponential in the tree size
and
by prior methods there really haven't
been too many i'm going to mention
two mccfr and another piece of work that
i did with my student gabriela farina
but this is by and large
a new area of trying to compute
equilibria in these black box games
that really are game theoretic
equilibria in the full game
not just in the part of the model that
you have actually generated
so black box games here the game is not
explicitly given in the form of rules
like maybe in poker uh but rather it's
accessible only by playing the game
so somebody gives you the uh let's say
xbox game you get that for christmas
and uh and now you get to play in it and
you get to learn to play
but nobody tells you the list of rules
of some xbox game
here the a i can control
all players during the practice phase
so i don't in the practice phase have to
play against an adversary
uh and in the practice phase also i can
make
catastrophic mistakes to learn from the
game
and how to play the game what are the
rules and how to play it
and these catastrophes don't really cost
me anything because i'm just practicing
am i sitting on my couch playing xbox by
myself
as the ai so this is
not a regret minimization setting in the
sense that
we don't care about the payoffs during
the practice phase
we just want to have a stronger possible
strategy
by the end of the practice phase that
can be used against any opponent
and this this type of setting is
actually quite common
it happens in war games strategy video
games
financial simulations and so on so here
we have for example
uh pictures of uh starcraft 2 and dota 2
and then we're doing quite a bit of work
like this on on real world domains at
strategy robot
any questions on the setting i want this
to be super clear
that what's a black box game and i
wanted to be clear that we actually can
control
all of the players during the practice
phase and the rewards during the
practice phase
don't really cost us any real money
we're just using
that practice phase to learn what the
game is and try to learn to how to play
it well with guarantees
any questions on that
i can ask a question yes hi
so do we have access to the reward
system and do we have access to what
exact state
the agents are in and what exact action
they took
good good yeah let um i'm gonna answer
all of those
in detail those are great questions but
uh let me just postpone it because
that's coming up
okay okay all right let me move on then
so um how do we learn or we how does
anybody learn to play
black box games and there's been really
three approaches so far
uh two before this and this approach
so one uh and maybe
well not maybe the most predominant
approach
has been deep reinforcement learning and
deep reinforcement learning is
inherently a
single agent technique and has
guarantees only for the single agent
setting
but it has found some practical amazing
success
in some of these real-time strategy
games like alpha star
playing starcraft 2 or open ai 5
playing dota 2 and those are pictures of
that
so uh that's in great practical
performance for a while
so for example in both of those examples
ais that have been generated with deep
reinforcement learning
sometimes with prior human play
knowledge to start out with sometimes
not
have reached levels where they can
actually
beat a world champion team
however there's a major issue with those
approaches
which is that they give no
exploitability bounce
and if you think about what game theory
really is
what's game theory equilibrium finding
this is what it really is
it tries to find strategies that have
these exploitability guarantees
that no strategy can exploit me more
than epsilon
and because it has no exploitability
bounce it's actually not just a
theoretical problem
it leads to strategies that can be
beaten in practice also
so for example in dota 2 after they had
beaten
the world champion team after a few
weeks
even average players were able to beat
the ai once they had found the
weaknesses
in the strategy
so again no exploitability bounce and it
manifests in practice as well
in that even average players can beat it
another approach this joint work with my
student gabrielle farina
is bandit regret minimization it's
different than what i'm going to talk
about today
in that it's really minimizing regret
along the way there's no free practice
phase
and also we're not controlling both
players there we're controlling just one
player and it needs to learn the game
against anybody and bandit
that's important here in that we're only
getting feedback on the actions that we
actually took on the game
we're not getting feedback on the
actions that we didn't take
uh like most traditional equilibrium
finding algorithms for this space
they are not banded they assume that you
get feedback on all of the actions
not just actions on your that you took
this converges to epsilon equilibrium
after a number of samples in the game
that's polynomial in n the size of the
game counted as the number of notes
and one over epsilon where epsilon is
the excellent guarantee
on exploitability and what's a sample in
this talk
a sample in this talk is one playthrough
in the game so from the root to the leaf
that is a sample it's not the full
traversal of the game tree and it's not
just one action
again a sample is a play through
issues here with this approach and also
mc online mccfr has these issues and
also other issues
the worst case exploitability pounds are
trivial until the number of iterations
is much larger than n
and you need to expand the rest of the
game tree to compute
exposed exploitability guarantees so
there's two ways to get guarantees in
game solving really
one is the worst case exploitability
bounce
that say that for any game this
algorithm is going to find an epsilon
that's at most this big but here these
worst case bounds
are trivial until the number of
iterations that you run the algorithm is
much larger than the game
and the other approach is that you can
just try to run an algorithm
and then you check at the end how bad is
the exploitability
by doing a best response computation and
to do a best risk response computation
you need to expand the rest of the game
tree here
so you have basically no hope unless you
have some additional structure maybe
of finding an exposed guarantee without
actually revisiting
the entire game tree which is way too
big in
all of these examples
okay so now let me move to certificates
which is the approach
uh in in this talk
here we want to compute the nash
equilibrium of the game
or an epsilon nash equilibrium by
incrementally expanding the game tree
and we can compute exploitability bounds
exposed without ever expanding
the remainder of the tree so we're gonna
only expand
part of the game three and then we get
both these
worst case game independent bounds and
we can also come up with these
game specific and strategy specific
exposed
exploitability guarantees without
actually expanding the whole game tree
okay so now coming to your question anna
now we're going to start to talk about
what this looks like and
here's a very sim a very small example
we're gonna talk about uh
uh experiments that have
uh millions of notes in the game trees
even in
infinite game trees and so on but i
wanna show you a small example here
just to make it clear so here we have in
this example
two players player one and player two
and
chance so this is a standard extensive
form game representation
uh if uh
it's as if it's a zero-sum game which we
assume for part of this talk
then you have just player once payoffs
shown in the leaves and player two's
payoff is just one minus that
if we have a general sum game then you
would have to leave
a vector of payoffs one player for every
player
and in this example player 1 could go
left and right and
if player 1 goes left then player 2
would go left or right
if player 1 goes right then chance plays
50 50 left or right
and then player 2 gets to go left or
right and that dotted line there is an
information set that represents
imperfect information
it says that player two at that
information set
doesn't know what chance did so player
doesn't know whether he's in the left
of those notes or the right of those
notes
all right so that's an extensive form
game and that's exactly the
representation that we work on
nothing uh new yet
now let me introduce two notes new
notions
a pseudo game and a certificate
a pseudo game is a game without known
utilities
on all terminal nodes so for example i
could say
ah i haven't really expanded the
game 3 fully but somehow i know that
at that left node the payoff for player
one
is non-positive
so that would be an example of a sort of
game it's a partially expanded
game three
in zero sum land this gives rise to
actually
two different games a lower bound game
in which the rewards are optimized for
player two
so in this game here we would assume
that
player one's payoff at that left node
is minus infinity
and an upper bound game in which the
rewards are optimistic
for player 1 and here we would assume
that that node's payoff would be zero
any questions on that
okay we call that
a pseudo-terminal node because it's a
terminal node of our pseudo game
but it is not a terminal node of the
real game
okay so an approximate nash equilibrium
in a pseudogame
is a strategy profile in which every
player is probably playing
an approp approximate best response
irrespective of what happens at
pseudo-terminal nodes
so let's do an example so here
the green numbers show a strategy
profile
so player one goes left with zero
probability right with one
chance plays as before and player two
randomizes 50 50 between going left and
right
you can convince yourself that this is
actually an exact nash equilibrium
of of the game why
well if player 1 moves right
then player 2 can do no better than zero
expected utility
and he can get that with playing half
half
and if player two plays half half player
one
is going to get zero by moving right and
at most zero by moving left
so player one might as well move right
so this is not even an approximate nash
equilibrium here
this is an exact nash equilibrium here
and furthermore it's an exact nash
equilibrium
of the real full game not just of the
pseudo game
so we didn't need to expand the whole
full game here
to be able to determine what the nash
equilibrium of the real game is
and this is kind of the main insight of
the of the paper
and now there's a lot of technical stuff
that i'm going to go into
in the rest of the thought but if you
want to remember one bit this is a one
bit
this is the idea
so this results in a nash equilibrium
regardless of what the pseudo-terminal
node hides
and what's a certificate here
a certificate it's a pseudo game created
from
partial expansion of the full game plus
a nash equilibrium of that sort of game
so we need to have the strategies and we
need to have the pseudo game
that proves that the strategies
are indeed nash equilibrium or
approximate nash
so we're certifying that the nash
equilibrium is indeed a nash equilibrium
by having this partially expanded gain
tree which we call a soda game
okay now we can ask okay yeah you just
made up
an example where you didn't have to
expand the whole game tree
uh how well does this work in practice
when
when does it lead to small certificates
or is it the case that in most games you
pretty much have to expand the whole
game tree anyway
so ask a question please uh yes how do
you certify
that the the values that you have on the
pseudo games are correct
so i understand that you give yourself
like this red now can you see my cursor
yes
i mean how do we guarantee that this
bound here this red bound is correct
yes oh we that is a given those are
those are inputs to the algorithm
these come from the simulator and um uh
and and i'm gonna talk about how much
sampling you need to do
and how do you do the sampling and
things like that in the rest of the talk
but uh these are coming from the c
from the simulator and if they don't
come from the simulator
if the simulator says i don't know then
the bounce can be minus infinity and
infinity
and it's still the whole thing still
works you don't have to have finite
bounds on everything
of course the tighter the bounce that
the simulator can give you
the smaller the certificate that's
needed
okay so when do smaller certificates
exist
when do small certificates exist and
specifically what do we mean by small
here
we're saying certificates of size
order into the c and
times polynomial in one over epsilon
for some c less than one n is the size
of the game tree
in nodes so we don't wanna have to
expand the whole game tree
this is just saying that you know we
want to expand less than the whole game
three when can we do that
um
okay i'm gonna give you many answers i'm
gonna start with
two very intuitive settings where i can
explain quickly
that there's always always short
certificates
and then i'm gonna move to the real
imperfect information extensive form
where it really depends on the game but
one answer
is that they always exist in perfect
information
zero some games with no nature
randomness
and why is that oh by the way minor
caveats here
under reasonable assumptions of the game
tree so there are certain
weird game trees um
that you could construct where it's not
quite the case but
under reasonable assumptions about the
game tree for example
a roughly uniform branching factor and
depth and alternating moves
the proof is very simple it actually
heavily relies on something that's
already known
which is that the optimal alpha beta
search tree
is a certificate and in particular from
all results by
knuth the size of the certificate
is roughly square root of n
so in perfect information games you can
actually
get away with a certificate of size
square root of n
another example is that they exist in
normal form games
so normal form games are matrix form
games
and here again a small caveat there they
have to be square-ish
so not something that has a huge number
of strategies for one player and almost
nothing for the other
so here's an example so um the column
player
can gets to pick some strategy between a
and g
and the role player between t and z
that's a normal form game
and uh how come does the uh how how do
we know that that has
small certificates well there's a result
by lipton ethel from 2003
that says that there's an epsilon nash
equilibrium where each player mixes
between
only log m divided by epsilon square
squared pure strategies where m
is the number of strategies for a player
so what that results lipton's result
says that okay there's some
small support for the column player and
some small support for the role player
such that the mixed strategy played on
only those supports
is an epsilon equilibrium
okay so now how do we convert that into
a certificate
that's not quite enough so what we can
do
for a certificate we only need those
rows and columns
but we also need all of the
other cells for those rows
for the column player and all of the
other cells for those
columns for the role player because we
want to make sure
that the opponent can't switch to
something
else and significantly exploit us so
that's why we get an extra factor of
m here here and
we can this shows that you get an order
m log m
divided by epsilon squared size
certificate
again a very small certificate
suffices
so small certificate existing games
where the players have perfect
information
or no information the
normal phone case is the no information
games
but what about in between
a lot of these imperfect information
games are in between perfect information
and no information
what happens there and that's what i'm
going to talk about in the rest of this
talk
can i ask a question yes
so i i think it's probably related to
the previous question so
it's it's what's confusing is that you
don't know you
you don't know how to find these
certificates so how how can you exploit
this to solve the games
faster oh yes i haven't given you any
algorithms yet so far it's all about
existence i'm going to give you many
algorithms later in this talk
okay okay sure assignment yeah thanks
no you're you that's good you're you're
jumping ahead and that shows that
you're on the ball that's great so
unfortunately
small certificates don't always exist
uh here's an example consider this game
where you have matching pennies
where one of the players tries to
there's this uh you can either choose
heads or tails and the other guy can
choose heads or tails
one player wants them to be the same the
other player wants them to be different
that's matching pennies here we're going
to repeat the matching pennies t
times each round worth one over t
points after each round
player two learns what player one played
but player one doesn't learn anything
so player one doesn't observe anything
this is our
counter example game and
the game tree size here is four to the
power of t
because at every round
each player has two choices so uh
at every round there are two times two
is four choices total
and there's three rounds now the theorem
is that any epsilon certificate
of this game must have size omega 4 to
the t
times one minus order epsilon
so you need to basically have the whole
game tree expanded before
you can certify nash equilibrium in this
case
this is of course highly tweaked the
manual bad case
the proof sketch is just that player one
strategy must have high entropy
but this is not possible unless lots of
nodes get expanded
now continuing with bad news
computational hardness
it's np hard to approximate a smaller
certificate of an extensive form zero or
some gain
to better than order log n
multiplicative factor
the proof idea here is just a reduction
from set cover
one guy tries to uh in a certain game
tries to just
cover all of the other players options
now let's let's start to talk about a
little bit more detail of the simulator
what kind of access we want
and i'm going to start from our first
paper
on this which was the nurex 20 paper and
then i'm going to relax what we need
to talk about some of the
work in the aaai 21 paper
[Music]
so we're gonna assume access to a
simulator this is the black box
that our game learner is accessing
so think about xbox you just got some
xbox game for christmas
and that's your simulator
we can play the game or the ai can play
the game
from the perspective of all players at
once so the ai can
know what each one of the players
observes in the game
and and the player can control what each
one of the
players does in the game but of course
the game 3 is so
huge that even with that control you
can't play through all of the paths
the simulator gives bounce which don't
have to be tight
on future utilities like let's say that
i've lost a
lost a huge asset on by making a big
mistake
i know that okay i can't get the maximum
payoff of the game
because i've already lost this huge
asset that was very valuable simulator
also allows us to control
nature actions here and this is the
thing that i'm going to relax later in
this talk
but i want to start simple so and what
this allows me to do
it allows me to take the game into any
state from the root
and then continue playing it from there
so in other words i get to jump around
in the game tree as much as i want
in the second part of the talk i'm going
to remove that and say that i can
only start from the root of the game
and xbox is going to take me wherever
xbox wants me to
want to take me and i cannot control the
path
nature notes
[Music]
the goal is to compute and verify an
exposed approximate equilibrium with
only this black box
access and exposed means that
it can be game specific and it can be
strategy specific
so i'm going to have this learning phase
and at the end of the learning phase i
can do an extra step of computation that
i want
and then somehow compute
how good my strategy is and then that
strategy
has to be good against any future
opponent
so when we measure how good the strategy
is in exploitability
we do it in the normal game theoretic
sense of
finding the toughest opponent in other
words the best response to our strategy
we're going to output both an
equilibrium strategy and the bound
epsilon the exposed bond epsilon that we
compute more bad news
with only black box uh simulation
of an expensive pharmacy even zero sum
game there's no equilibrium finding
algorithm
that runs in time polynomial in the size
of the smallest certificate somehow
not that surprising because you could
actually generate games that have very
small certificates
but they might be hard to find and the
proof is a one-player set game
the certificate is of size the smallest
certificate is of the size
order log n but
there's no sublinear time it's basically
trying to find a satisfying assignment
to the variables
now we're going to do it anyway yes it
shows that there are
bad cases but we can now generate an
algorithm to do it anyway
and then we're going to see how fast it
is in practice
in runtime and in terms of a number of
samples it needs
so what we're going to do here we're
going to repeat until satisfied
you can put in your favorite stopping
criteria there
we're going to solve both the upper
bound and lower bound sudo games exactly
for example using an lp solver in the
sequence form we're going to create the
next
pseudo game by expanding all
pseudo-terminal nodes in the support of
the optimistic profile
in which the max player plays her
equilibrium strategy in the upper bound
game
and the mean player plays her strategy
in the lower bound game
so this is in some certain sense a game
theoretic
interpretation of this classical mantra
mantra
of optimism under uncertainty
for exploration and then we're gonna
output
the pessimistic profile and epsilon
which is the difference in values
between the upper and lower bound
sure games in the pessimistic profile
so when we give the guarantees we have
to be pessimistic
but when we're doing the exploration as
to what to expand next
we're optimistic and the intuition is
that
if you want to hang your hat on
something in the perfect information
setting
with no nature randomness this is just
alpha beta search
but this is more general because it
applies to imperfect information games
the theorem here is that the expansion
in the second step expands a node if and
only if the game is not already solved
so in that sense it's not doing any
unnecessary work and
therefore if you run this long enough it
will find a nash equilibrium
this works even on games that have
unbounded rewards
so let me show some experiments here
the first is a search game which is a
standard benchmark in the field
it has about 200 000 nodes
11 000 information sets and we see that
the size of the certificate these fines
is about
five or six percent of the uh size of
the game
then in a group spiel which is a
standard benchmark
we actually make three variants of
gauche pill one is the perfect
information variant
then there's a real goof spill and then
there's a goof spill where the cars come
in random order
instead of sorted order and we can
control
the num size of the game by how many
different ranks there are in golf spill
so here we're going from four rank to
six rank
we're going from games with about a 2
000 notes to games to about
nine million notes and uh what what do
we see here
well in all of the cases it works and
the bigger the game the smaller the
fraction
of the size of the certificate so um
that's good we see that in the perfect
information variant we get to very small
fractions like one percent or even half
a percent already
at this size in these imperfect
information games
the certificates are relatively larger
we're looking at like 10
or 20 but again the bigger the game
the smaller the percentage so this
becomes more powerful in the bigger
games
and then in leduc poker and we can vary
the number of ranks to vary the size
the game three is actually infinite
because we allow an
infinite number of re-raises in this
variant
so these are infinite games but we can
still
uh solve them with uh and get relatively
small
certificates
okay now i'm gonna move to more
realistic simulators
this is what we had before the simulator
allows us to play through the game from
the perspective of both players it gives
bounce
and allows us to control nature nodes
now i'm going to
take this one away we can no longer
control the nature nodes
instead we have to always start by
playing at uh
from the root and the game is just
taking its own nature actions and we're
controlling
only the player actions
okay so now we can't
really ever be sure about the
probabilities
of the nature actions at the nature node
because we if we get unlucky there are
some actions
that nature never gives us or
or they're so low probability that we
didn't see them in the training phase
but we might see them in actual play
later
and they might be catastrophic so we
can't get
guarantees for sure so here we want
probabilistic guarantees
and we want to say correctness with high
probability say 1 minus t
to the minus gamma for some gamma
greater than 0
after the iterations
now here's a roadmap for the rest of the
talk
this splits based on what happens in the
chance node
in our new rips 20 paper we looked at
the case where a chat when we visit the
chance node it gives the full
distribution at that node
what are all of the actions as chance
would take and their probabilities
now we're going to talk about a chance
notice where we don't get
all of the actions and we don't get
their probabilities
we just get one sample from the
probability distribution
of the chance node that we visit
here if we're in the sampling limited
case
where the simulator is very slow like
we're seeing in a lot of our real world
cases where one playthrough takes
over half an hour so clearly in those
settings we're
sampling limited and that's very
different that let's say dota 2 or
starcraft 2
which ais can play against each other
very quickly
there when it's sampling limited we i'm
going to show you an algorithm that uses
an lp
because we can afford to solve the lp
exactly and therefore do the reasoning
very
well in order to minimize the number of
samples
when on the other hand we're in a
compute limited setting where the
equilibrium finding reasoning is a
bottleneck
and accessing the simulator is fast
that's more like the starcraft type of
setting
or poker if you like to play poker as a
black
box game there we're gonna have a new
algorithm
that uses regret minimization as part of
it
and um that is usable even in general
some games not just zero sum
and in those cases it computes course
correlated equilibrium
instead of nash as regret minimizers
usually do
but never in this setting before this
black box setting
okay so the lower bound for this setting
consider any algorithm with the
following guarantee
for some constant gamma greater than
zero
given a zero sum game in our black box
setting
with t game samples again each sample is
a play through
the algorithm up outputs a pair of
strategies x y
and a bound epsilon t such that with
probability one minus
order t to the minus gamma x y is an
epsilon nash equilibrium
then the lower bound is like this the
epsilon is omega
of square root of log t over t
and our goal uh by the way we proved
this in the paper
our goal is to match this part with
actual
algorithms
the main tool is sure games as
confidence bounce here
and notice that we have not yet expanded
we use bounds given by the simulator
as before and at nature nodes
h we give each player
a made-up reward that's bounded by
minus from minus row to row where
rho is computed as follows
so first there's the delta factor which
is the range of utilities
that are possible from that node h
onward
and then there's this uh other factor
which is square root
of 1 over 2 t h where th
is the number of times that h has been
reached so far
times log 1 over epsilon sorry 1 over
delta
where delta is the confidence parameter
remember we wanted uh
to have
so the intuition here is that rho
represents the uncertainty in the nature
distribution
at the node nature node h
the intuition well if you're familiar
with uc
b upper confidence bounds
this looks a lot like that but not
exactly and this is not a coincidence
as i'll discuss later
the choice of confidence bound well so
far what i showed you on the previous
slide is this
during the equilibrium computation the
values of the children are changing
so we need to use a shifting bound to be
robust
for raw and that's what we did
now here's a new idea that has we had
since uh the
aaai 21 paper
during the best response computation at
the end
after the equilibrium finding the
strategy profile
after h below h in the tree
is fixed by induction because we have
already fixed the opponent's strategy
the nature
strategies are fixed by definition
and we have already fixed our own
strategy below that point
because we're computing the best
response bottom up
by induction so during the best response
the strategy profiles after h are fixed
so where you can use a tighter
empirical bernstein bound this is a
formula for motor and pontil in a
different context
it doesn't matter that much but here s
is the unbiased sample standard
deviation and delta prime is the range
of possible utilities from h
under the fixed strategy profile which
may be much smaller
smaller than the original delta
okay so we can actually use a different
confidence bound technique during the
equilibrium finding and a title one
in the best response computation so we
can get an even tighter best response
bound epsilon for those same strategies
that we're computing using that row
technique
the original row technique by the way
that's
so new that we haven't yet implemented
that so that in the experiments i'm
going to show you we're not using that
yet
we're just using the former technique
for row so the new
results will be even better but i just
don't know yet how much better
okay now pseudogames has confidence
bounds
here's the theorem that this is correct
that the way of doing those rows is
correct
for an appropriate choice of delta with
high probability
at every time for every strategy profile
for every player
the true reward of the player is pounded
by the pessimistic and optimistic
rewards
achieved in the confidence bounds order
game in other words
the confidence bounds are actually
bounced
and now to the algorithm so i'm going to
start from the lp based algorithm
we're going to repeat t times solve both
the upper
bound sort of game and lower bound sudo
game exactly
for example using an lp solver in the
sequence form
then we're going to sample one
playthrough from the optimistic profile
again
in which the max player again plays our
equilibrium strategy in the upper bound
game
and the mini player plays her strategy
in the lower bound game
so this is again optimism under
uncertainty for the sampling
and then we're going to create the next
pseudo game
we expand all of the encountered nodes
during that sample
and we're going to update the empirical
nature distributions of
nature nodes sampled during that play
the output is the pessimistic profile
again
and epsilon t is the difference in
values again between the upper and lower
bounds order games
the intuition again is that in the
perfect information setting
with no nature randomness it's still
just alpha beta search
and in the one player multi-unbanded
setting it's ucp
well not exactly in that the algorithm
has a different constant in the upper
bound conference bound term
and and a different constant in the
regret bound but essentially
uh specialized to the multi-unbanded
setting with just one player
it is ucb
okay so the advantage of that it's very
sample efficient
the disadvantage is that the iterations
are expensive because they require game
resolve
with exact lp on each iteration
we do warm start from the previous lp
whose values typically change very
little based on the one you
play through so you get a good warm
start and that helps
actually a huge amount but still you're
solving an exact
lp um
and here's the guarantee the best
iterate of the algorithm
converges at the rate of where the
expectation over t
is order in t
times log t over t
and n t is the size of the certificate
here
not the size of the whole game
and that's important because as we
showed the size of the certificate
can be much much smaller orders are
magnitude smaller than the total number
of nodes in the game
so now we're really looking at
complexity as a function of the size of
the certificate here
not as a function of the whole game and
that's what you want
and this is very different than how
people are typically looking at
equilibrium finding typically it's
always as a function of the size of the
game
okay now
when you're in a setting where you're
not so much sample bound but you compute
bound you don't want to solve the exact
lp every time you do a sample
so that's why we have this regret based
algorithm for that setting
and the idea is just to use a regret
minimizer like cfr
for each player what we do we again
repeat the times
we query the regret minimizers for all
players to obtain a strategy profile
then we sample one playthrough from that
strategy profile
we pass each player's regret minimizer
that player's optimistic reward
create the next sudo game by expanding
all of the encountered nodes again
and by updating the empirical nature
distributions of nature nodes sampled
during play
and we output the average strategy
profile as typically in
in cfr
now these are several problems one the
strategy space of each player is
changing over time
so you're not actually solving the same
game you're actually solving a different
game
at every iteration this is okay
cfr handles this naturally we actually
in the paper we formalize what's
required in terms of
extendable regret minimizers in the
interest of time i'm not going to go
into that
but suffice it to say that cfr is one
extendable regret minimizer
some regret minimizers are not
extendable
problem two we don't want to run a full
cfr iterate on every sample
that's expensive so what we do
we use monte carlo cfr plus outcome
sampling
which is a standard technique and
nothing breaks then
and then the third question or problem
is what equilibrium gap
bound can we now get given that we're
not solving the lp
exactly and
that's what i'm going to talk about now
the natural game specific equilibrium
gap bound
which is what we used in the lp based
algorithm again which was the difference
in optimistic best response value
using the final sort of game doesn't
converge
as o tilde one over epsilon squared in
the worst case
there are these pesky cases where
you have these low probability actions
that we talked about but we know that
the worst case over
games equilibrium gap bound of the
algorithm
does converge as o tilde one over square
root of t
for the same reason that mccfr does so
what we can do
in practice we just take the former it's
basically always smaller in practice
in theory you could compute both bounds
and take the minimum of the two
so that's how you get the best of both
worlds
all right let me finish with some
experiments
and now these are experiments with this
with this new algorithm
and that uses a more realistic access
where you just get one sample of a
nature node
when you get to a nature node so the
nature node doesn't tell you all of the
actions that are available
or die that doesn't tell you all of the
probabilities on all of the actions
and these are pretty dense so let me now
walk through kind of what's what
on the x-axis we have iterations on the
on a log scale each iteration does one
is one sample
followed by that computation and one
sample is one playthrough
and on the y axis we have the nash gap
on
a log scale so lower is better
we have here we have this horizontal
line is a range
of uh players reward
in the full game so if we're above that
we have really no guarantee on the gap
we're trivial
below that line we're non-trivial
and then the horizontal sorry vertical
line here is a number of nodes in the
full game so
as long as we're on the left side of the
that line
we have not yet expanded the whole game
so we're getting some benefit
and what we see here let's look at the
solid lines
these are their certificate
lp algorithm and the certificate mccfr
algorithm that i talked to you about
and we see that they are non-trivial we
are getting big
benefit and um we can also see
what are the actual exploitabilities uh
with those the dotted blue and green
lines and they're as you would expect
better than the uh worst case bounds
we also uh
ran um mccfr as a benchmark
and it's kind of an unfair benchmark in
that it doesn't give you any guarantees
but because we know the current game we
can actually compute an export guarantee
ourselves for using the whole game
uh so that's mca fire how well it
performs
on that game so here is the best here is
not quite the best
but again it cannot give you guarantees
without expanding the whole game tree
so it's not really an actual competitor
more like a theoretical benchmark here
in this case okay
um and um
on the figure here on the bottom same
x-axis
certificate size on the y-axis and
we see that uh yes the certificate size
is uh uh
much less than the number of full notes
in the game tree
as you want as you would want
so in all of the games with all
algorithms
we find non-trivial certificates without
expanding the full game
and in fact with fewer game samples and
there are game three nodes
mccfr converges quickly in reality but
doesn't give you bounce so it's more
like a theoretical benchmark
and we see that getting these
theoretical guarantees
only costs us about a factor of five
so uh we need to do
five times more samples but with that we
can actually get guarantees
[Music]
and as you would expect the lb-based
certificate finding has better sample
efficiency
and final certificate size than the
regret paste because it was
geared towards sample efficiency while
the regret base was
geared more towards computational
efficiency
so depending whether you're sample bound
or compute bound
you might wanna choose one or the other
okay so let me conclude um
very short conclusion black box
imperfect information games
of at least moderate size now can be
solved
uh for the first time in other words we
can get the non-exploitability
guarantees of game theory
even in these settings where we don't
know what the game is
and this here are some the two papers on
this
and then in addition we talked about the
new concentration result
for which we don't have experiments yet
okay
let's take any further questions you may
have
okay thanks thomas questions everybody
rupak um
thank you for this really fascinating
talk um i'm coming from a
somewhat different area where we're
trying to look at uh
you know um control design problems in
dynamical systems
now if you look at your setting of these
black box games where you can simulate
the system dynamics
also in the presence of certain
environment disturbances
how many of your computational results
do you think would transfer to a setting
where essentially we are trying to find
winning strategies
in these kind of dynamical system games
right so i want to find a
robust controller against some
environment noise
i can simulate the system you know any
number of times
can i use your algorithms in this
setting as well or is there something
specific to the games that you're
looking at
that makes these algorithms better
uh so i don't think there's anything
specific
in these games uh
uh if you're talking about the benchmark
selection here we try to come
up you use kind of standard benchmarks
from a host of different
domains uh um
there's different types of card games
there's poker there's cool spiel which
is a trick taking game instead
there's the search game which is kind of
a
structured graph graph-based security
game um
uh and then there were the but you see
my question is
if i were to take your algorithms and
apply them let us say to
robot control which often is this kind
of a two-player game between the
controller and the
disturbance in some kind of imperfect
information setting
i don't see any reason why they would
not transfer right so
yeah i don't either well let me say
one where i would look for i don't know
that there's a problem
but in transferring them but where i
would look for that one
is that here we're assuming
that the branches are discrete so the
actions are discrete they're not
continuous but
maybe you could discretize the action
and you might take some loss there we
actually have a paper with christian
career
uh that looks at the loss that you get
in game theoretic settings from
discretization
and how should you do the discretization
to minimize it a uniform discretization
is not best
but so you could look at that so there
are better ways to do
discretization than uniform but so
that's one where
maybe in some theoretical way this could
go astray
but but i i don't think so i think it
should be good
oh thank you very much okay
other questions
well we're waiting see if there any
other questions let me just ask so i
mean this is very much focused on
uh on i mean your work over the last few
years have been very focused on kind of
games like poker and so on
i mean other applications beyond game
playing i mean what
what realistically might it be used for
ultimately
oh yeah that's a that's a great question
and i actually believe so much in this
that there are real applications that i
founded two companies strategy robot and
strategic machine
to actually feel these in real
applications
we are actually doing real applications
um
i can't really say which applications
we're doing
but the press has gotten some wind of it
so if you wanna
uh uh poke around what the press has
said
you know that's uh that's something if
you wanna search on the strategy robot
the strategic machine
um you can see what the press
has said um i i think that you know uh
lots lots of different military games
there are a lot of zero-sum games in
defense
security games of different kinds
um and i don't mean just like
stackelberg
uh one shot that type of security game
but like security
in the kind of broad sense of the word
um
um there's
um uh i could give you a whole list of
vision things that i think okay
that's right imperfect information
auctions uh
options uh that don't have dominant
strategies
um one example by the way is the fcc
incentive auction the auction mechanism
that was
used for that is not a dominant strategy
mechanism
so each speeder's best strategy depends
on the other bitter strategies and
nobody knows even one rational bidding
strategy
and yet they uh reverse auctioned
almost a 100 almost 100 billion dollars
i think tens of in any case tens of
billions of dollars
of spectrum with that type of mechanism
where nobody knows how to bid rationally
so it would be nice wouldn't it be nice
if we could be rational in that
[Music]
negotiation bargaining political
campaigns where it's like okay how much
i should spend on different things and
in different
areas depends on how much my opponent
does and what
how they exactly allocate product
portfolio optimization
that's basically done as a single agent
optimization today assuming that
the competitors don't have a competitive
response which is of course wrong
pricing same thing today it's optimized
as a single
agent optimization assuming that others
don't change their prices
which couldn't be further from the truth
uh and so
okay very cool okay any other questions
see anything come in
oh it's a question from centil sentinel
roger saccharine hello central nice to
you uh nice to see you again
virtually it seems like different
techniques would be needed to lift these
techniques to
more than two player games is this
something you're interested in
or have looked at already uh for example
d-o-t-a
actually i don't know what that stands
for which has 10 players
oh okay so um let me start from the last
question
last part of the question it is not true
so
dota 2 uh is uh a two player zero sum
game
yes each player is a played by a team
typically of five players but it's still
a two player zero sum game
so uh that's not a multiplayer game
per se and stay with the same with
starcraft that's a two player zero sum
game so i think that these techniques
uh except for the scalability question
these would apply directly to dota 2 or
starcraft 2.
now i am not saying that these
certificates are going to be small
enough for those games
that i don't know and and that's i think
an interesting question because that's
how
when we would really be able to say
where really is the boundary
or what game3d techniques with
guarantees can do
for what size of game can you give
guarantees i believe that there's always
going to be a size of the game
that's too big that you cannot give game
30 guarantees
and then you work on some on unguaranted
techniques like deep reinforcement
learning
but um where is that boundary
i i don't know with these techniques
certainly now that at least the
field is open and we we know at least
it is working to an extent on these
reasonably sized games
of millions of nodes in the game trees
and we're not even pushing the
scalability boundary with millions
it certainly goes way beyond that but
i'm not saying that this can solve dota
2 or starcraft 2.
there's we're actually on ongoing
thinking that we're doing in the lab
of additional structure if you have some
additional structure about the game
certain independencies and other things
you can actually solve much bigger games
if you know that the games have those
structures even if you don't know
exactly what the game is
like one of my favorite examples is like
you know if you have a
let's say some real-time strategy game
that has a little gremlin
that's fighting at your ankles and and
pestering you
it is not going to turn into a nuclear
weapon that's going to explode
everything at the end
it's going to always be that kremlin and
maybe it's going to get a little worse
or a little
better you know whatever but it's not
gonna completely change
and and and otherwise the game wouldn't
be interesting if some of the gran
gremlins mysteriously turn into a
nuclear weapon in the game
so there's something about games that
have this type of consistency
that humans like and can understand that
already
puts restrictions on what the game
strategy space can be
and if we can somehow characterize as to
what are those restrictions that would
be helpful for
bounding what the unknown pieces of the
game might be
in terms of bounds and so on that would
probably really increase the scalability
of these guaranteed approaches
very good uh scentil says i thought
dota had four teams but i don't know
much about it honestly but thank you for
the answer and the interesting talk
okay if that's that's made maybe there's
some sort of a dota
that has four teams i don't know about
it the dlta stuff that i know about is
two teams or five players each
[Music]
any other questions i'm not seeing any
hands up and i'm not seeing any other
questions come in
the chat uh
rupak as another question just a quick
follow-up to that i mean if you're
modeling a five-player game
as you know the five versus five as a
zero sum
uh two coalition game you're kind of
making an assumption that these five
players have all the same knowledge you
know that they're correlated in their
strategies
but this may yeah that's right they do
they do in in dota 2
you know if you put an ai to play it you
you could you can have the ai look at
all of the input from all of the five
but but you're right i mean we're also
looking at kind of coalitional games
for other settings where you cannot
coordinate during the play
but you can coordinate before the game
so i can actually coordinate my
strategies
in advance but i can't coordinate my
information
during play that's also a very
interesting setting and we
have other papers on that but that's not
what this this this pair of papers
addresses
thank you
okay any other questions
no okay i think then uh we've come to an
end
so on behalf of everybody thank you very
much joyness for giving a typically
a typically energetic and
thought-provoking talk
it's great to see your latest work and
it's going to be fascinating to see how
that work unfolds in the next few years
um i think what i what i love about this
is
uh it's not all just deep learning right
that's not the only game in town i think
that's what the message that i'm going
to take home from this
which is a great message to take home so
thanks everybody for joining us
and uh tune in uh tune in for the next
talk the details you'll find on the
simon's institute website
thanks again to emma thanks a lot it's
great fun